i suppose we can uh we can start with
one of two things obviously i brought up
critical race theory but also the
vaccine issue i'm not sure if you guys
have a preference
for what you're talking about the
vaccine why don't we talk about what's
going on with uh vaccine passports sure
we've seen in sydney for instance they
issued a lockdown
most or i should say enough people
ignored it they went out in the streets
and then this resulted in news articles
saying chaos in sydney people aren't
uh you know they're not following the
rules the vaccination rate in australia
is ridiculously low i think it's 18
really really low well then they called
in uh police
and they were big protests now they've
actually deployed military so i'm
curious if either if
you want to jump in with your thoughts
on mandates what would happen if they
came here if you're for or against them
look there are elements of mandates that
i can agree with we've already set
standards for other things like the
mmr vaccine very basic standard vaccines
that we expect everyone get before they
can
go to school travel and i think for the
most part that's worked we've eradicated
plagues from the world i think we should
be proud of that
with regards to kovitz since this is an
ongoing pandemic
we need to focus on approaches that are
effective and that don't
ostracize or exacerbate tensions with
regard to the australian situation it's
not something i'm extensively familiar
with but generally speaking i don't
think that cracking down on protests
is going to be an effective way to
incentivize people to get vaccinated
what's happening in new york might be
but my main issue with it is that i'm
not entirely sure how they
expect people to still have their
vaccination card i know that there's
been some confusion from the beginning
as to whether or not you should keep
that i know people have thrown theirs
away
they made it too big for wallets it just
felt a little bit
haphazardly planned from the foreground
so that's unfortunate
maybe they can find other ways to
incentivize it like for example in
schools
where they have a direct access to
government records where they wouldn't
have to use those
um those little cards you know that
might be a little bit better i guess
we'll have to see
well not saying you believe this but
some people on the left i never want to
hear about the discussion of voter id
ever again
because now you can force people to
identify their medical history to try to
get into a restaurant in new york city
yeah look i'm not getting the vaccine so
i'm part of the 100 million people that
are unvaccinated
and it's an experimental vaccine the fda
and cdc has said that in january
it's questionably effective lindsey
graham just came down with covid
you had a vessel a ship in the united
kingdom 100 vaccinated ship
that came down with covid it's more it's
more like a treatment
than a vaccine i'll leave that
conversation at dr brett weinstein and
the people that really understand um how
that works
but yeah this is medical apartheid this
is this is trying to create
a two-tiered system where if you don't
make the proper medical decisions
you're not able to go to broadway shows
or go into restaurants
even when the efficacy of this vaccine
is questionable at best we see that in
israel an 85 vaccinated country that's
about to lock down again
and most of the new cases are from
vaccinated patients not unvaccinated
patients in israel
so sorry you want to interject him but
yeah yeah obviously against mandates and
i think people should be able to make
their own medical decisions i think it's
pretty obvious well i disagree i think
we actually have a we actually have a
story wrote on timcast.com that
our view of the lockdowns is that it's
alarmism because a new study from the
public health of england found the
pfizer vaccine is 96
effective after two doses at staving off
the delta variant and astrazeneca was 92
percent
i could probably agree it's alarmism but
it's enough of an alarm
for the public health leaders to
undermine the argument that the vaccine
is a solution to what would possibly
satisfy the public so i mean i was
against the lockdowns in the first place
let me be very clear when where's a
thousand deaths a day not 334 but sorry
go ahead well a couple of points on this
first of all it's experimental in the
sense that there was an expedited
process for its release but there have
been full and extensive studies taken on
the safety and effectiveness of these
vaccines
the reason why the fda study hasn't been
finished the reason why it hasn't been
fully vetted
isn't because they're looking for
long-term health effects is because
they're determining
the extent to which it protects you over
a long period of time ergo
the fact of the matter is by all
available data this is undeniably
much safer to get the vaccine i mean by
orders of magic let me ask you a
question
wait a couple things because you said a
few things there um there are some
instances where areas have
more people being infected if they're
already vaccinated but if you take a
look at like
this is like data mining if you take a
look at the broader statistics
especially here in america
the number of people who have gotten
breakthrough cases is something like
0.003
of people who have been vaccinated you
can take a look at the numbers where
is this new wave exploding it's in the
unvaccinated
in spite of the fact that fewer and
fewer people are remaining unvaccinated
the vaccinated stay relatively healthy
and not only
do they get infected way less often they
also
suffer far fewer severe symptoms their
hospitalization rates have plummeted
and their deaths are incredibly low
compared to people who are unvaccinated
this is by all means an effective
vaccine what's your opinion of johnson
and johnson the fda saying that it might
cause a rare nerve disease
uh yeah that's something that first of
all when you take a look at that you
have to recognize that
even if that was the case which the fda
says it is right well they're looking
into it of course
it doesn't they they've issued an
official warning
that it could issue a rare nerve disease
that's a big deal could issue of course
they're looking into it and that is
something to look into and to be
concerned about what's your opinion of
vares the vaccine adverse event
reporting system hold on
first of all i'm just i'm just curious
because this is let's let's do the
gillian bear syndrome though i think
yeah so of course stuff like that can
happen now even if that claim is the
case it would remain the fact that
unless the extent of that potential
nerve damage is
just apocalyptically severe that the
effects of getting covet would still be
far far worse than the potential side
effects of that vaccine however
if you were to say let's say worst case
you know johnson and johnson it's not
viable that gets pulled we see what the
consequences are
that doesn't really speak against the
greater viability of the vaccines i got
pfizer for example
we're talking hundreds of millions of
people
who have either been protected against
the vaccine in part or if they get it or
sorry against the virus
or if they get it their effects their
symptoms are
much much much more so i just want to
just kind of just
play into the irony here that i'm the
one criticizing the pharmaceutical
companies and you're the ones that are
you're the one defending i just think
that's
that's it i think it's delicious that's
well wait that's extremely
dishonest well but you're you're
peddling the pfizer vaccine you're
saying it's
so effective wait i'm the one saying
hold on maybe astrazeneca maduro johnson
and johnson and pfizer this is let's
let's let's let's talk about the points
he's made and no i'm just i was just
enjoying the irony well it's well the
thing is it's not really like irony if
you understand the issue at hand see my
praise doesn't go to the pharmaceutical
companies or their ceos
it goes to the tireless workers who
spend months and months and months
developing these vaccines
very who's getting rich well hold on
have i at any point
praised the distribution or profiteering
system who do you think it's written for
vaccine mandates
this is pfizer's ceo nobody's talking
about who gets rich this is a change
isn't that your whole life hold up
this is a toothless critique let's hold
on let's try and go back and forth
this is a toothless critique that you
could apply to literally anything that
you don't like
everything in this country is
manufactured to the property
we don't mandate it and so you can't go
to restaurants if you don't get one of
these four
major farmers wait wait i just want to
say if that's your criticism that's one
of many then you should so if that's the
criticism you want to focus on
i'm in favor of nationalizing the
pharmaceutical industry i'm willing to
take it that far
but whether or not that's on the table
and i can't just make that happen
when we're talking strictly about the
effectiveness of the vaccine it seems so
let's not appraise of the capitalist
industry behind no i was just enjoying
the irony that it's not syringe well
it's totally ironic because i'm the one
saying that they might be lying to us
you're the one that's saying it's super
effective wait what
usually if we were wearing our
traditional uniforms right versus left
it would be the other way around that's
all i'm saying the only comments i'm
what do you have to say about the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
that says well over 7000 people
experience death after getting the
vaccine does that worry you um
the vera's system is entirely
self-reported i don't think it's
generally you think it's under-reported
or over-reported with theirs it's almost
impossible to say you know what varus is
right can you tell me what there is is a
government website that physicians or
individuals can submit complaints
or concerns after an adverse adverse
event report from a vaccine since you
cannot win in court
against a vaccine production company
then they go through some process where
the government then can distribute
some form of remedy if you had an
adverse event reaction right that's what
varies
and researchers like it because if you
take a vaccine or you get some other
procedure any medical drug done
you can report the effects there and it
can be a way of gathering sort of
aggregate data concerning the effects of
these um
of these potential treatments the
problem is uh researchers don't use this
as a bulletproof way of determining the
outcome or effect of anything because
they're literally just unvetted online
submissions that anybody can put in so i
ask you
i ask you because i want to know how do
you arrive at the conclusion that how
many people did you say
well it's versus own data is 7 000
plus and most of which by the way anyone
can submit no asking by the way most of
which are physicians submitted just so
you know
these are these are total number the
most of the submissions on the vera's
website are done by like family doctors
or local physicians so i'm just i'm just
asking but what what
number of adverse event reactions would
you say maybe there's something wrong
but i'm asking
10 000 deaths how do you know these
deaths
no i'm just saying that's what vera says
right no wait but i'm wait so i need to
know that
we don't so that's the question so wait
is these just people who have died
after taking the vaccine like they may
have died from some medical
incident afterwards and it just gets put
up this is the question because usually
a vaccine gets pulled when you have 15
attributable deaths we have 7 000 that
we have to go through the question is
when you call timeout and say
maybe you're not answering the question
how do you know that they're from the
vet
don't that's the point oh but you don't
either but the position is let's mandate
experimental medicine
we don't know actually what's going on
if you don't know then how can you say
that medical doctor is the one uploading
this information
is there any methodology or we can have
we do know who's actually uploading it
we know that
we know the entries are usually
typically traditionally
how about menstrual cycle disruption
loss of
nerve capacity unable to walk paralysis
miscarriages um mood changes also you
could go through the vares database like
oh that's interesting
what about the death let me let me
interject 7000 plus that's a serious
how do they know it's from the vaccine i
keep asking you this you don't let me
let me let me address two points one
from each of you real quick
so we can try and uh how do we know it's
from the vaccine it's a difficult
difficult question
uh i would say that if you have a mass
vaccination program which gives out 330
million doses or so
and then people start saying hey i got
the vaccine then this happened
theirs isn't here to say it is or isn't
they're here to say can we find a
pattern in this and i think 7000
suggests there may be one at the very
least
uh i'm not a scientist so i can't i
can't stress that i will also say
however to charlie
guillain-barre syndrome which i'm
probably pronouncing wrong always
mispronounce it
bar there my understanding is actually a
side effect of many vaccines
yeah it is and so totally that's correct
it could be well so so the issue i have
is
one of the things that brought up is
that there's been how many you mentioned
100
million 160 million 115 i think it is
millions
who have been folding vaccines i think
in that ballpark so
of course you know if you if you you
have something very different from
uh uh any other vaccination we normally
do because yeah we're not having
everyone do it all at once
yeah and so this is a mass inoculation
thing and so here's why the american
system
should answer this question easily when
you have any sort of uncertainty
or disagreement yield to rights so yield
to rights allow
so to say no let me just fill out the
argument right so for me for example
i'm 27 i don't consider covid to be a
largely disproportionate risk to my way
of life i don't know about this vaccine
i have gotten other vaccines in my life
so i want to be able to have the right
to say no to that so the american system
constitution
kind of like the tradition is to be able
to have people have nuance
preferences and individualism when it
comes to these sort of complex issues
not saying you can't go to a restaurant
because we want you to take experimental
medicine
right so a couple of points on that
first of all if we're speaking to legal
rights the
um supreme court found over a century
ago that one came to vaccinations this
was a special exemption from some
people's rights to
i will agree with you that the courts
are not on my side
in that one and there's a reason why
because of course when you choose not to
take the vaccine you contribute to the
um
removal of others freedoms see it's true
you do have a freedom
to not or to take a vaccine but i think
other people should have the freedom to
not grow up in a world
ridden by plague and with the way this
disease
covid mutates with time as all uh
diseases do
inevitably if it continues to circle the
world
long enough and this is an international
problem not just an american one
uh new strains will develop which will
slowly ebb at the effectiveness of this
set of vaccines so it threatens all of
us
may i say one other thing sorry sorry um
with all of that being said just to
speak to vars
varus is an incredibly effective system
for locating
and roughly attributing concerns related
to the effects of drugs
the problem is that there are several
elements to this disease that make it
really difficult to pinpoint anything
specific
the second the two of which being a
hundreds of millions of people
vaccinated that is a huge range to pull
data from
and b the you know uh propagandist fear
campaign about an incredibly effective
vaccine process that may lead people to
misunderstandings
just quick clarification uh are you for
mandating
the covid19 vaccine uh the same way we
have other vaccines like school
travel that kind of stuff yeah so like
what if someone want to go to a
restaurant or a supermarket or a movie
theater i think that
i mean we don't have that for other
vaccines right like every time you go to
a movie theater of a little card
i understand that might be an effective
panic measure but
long term my goal would be to integrate
it into the same revenue of vaccines i
think that's a more reasonable response
than some politicians
i'm just gonna be honest people are
panicking and i think that's a moral
i just want to make sure we weren't
having like you know misunderstanding no
i think that's more of a reasonable
answer
i'm i just just curious just on the
vaccine topic in general
are you concerned by like dr malone
coming out who literally
invented the mrna vaccine and says that
there's a dangerous spike protein
involved and he encourages people to
think twice before getting it
uh does that move you at all well you're
free to speak with your doctor when it
comes to
dr malone just his specific commentary
he's specifically the guy who invented
this type of valencia i'm not a phd and
i doubt that he was directly involved in
the production of these
he literally invented this the mrna but
with the like johnson johnson the pfizer
the
but he's very very aware of the sort of
accelerated implementation he's trying
to call timeout and tell
people this is not like any other
vaccine what does that worry you
his claim is that it involves a spike
protein it was rushed to market
it's going to have side effects you
don't understand it like i did i
invented this
and you got to think twice before
mandating it or even taking it if you're
under a certain age does that bother you
what makes the current retinue of
vaccines that we take the mrna process
different from other doesn't involve the
spike protein according to him
the same composition as like the measle
mumps rubella type vaccine or the
chickenpox
well those weren't mrna the process
wasn't developed back during the mmr
vaccine totally but some of them are
getting updated for the more mrna
type technology right he wasn't involved
in the production of these modern
vaccines how could he possibly have any
comment on
any of the rigors or tests because he
invented this type of vaccine i'm just
saying just does that bother do you
think he's just like a fear propagandist
and like no he may well have concerns
but those are concerns that i would
rather have addressed by the scientific
community rather than with respect to
you and myself
youtubers well no i i agree so but the
question is which scientists right
so there's a lot of scientists speaking
out against this dr brett weinstein
dr malone what was dr brett weinstein
he's an evolutionary biologist so he
knows a little bit about how that's not
foreign
do you trust fauci moore or dr brett
weinstein it's not about fauci it's
about
he's a virologist who's been wrong about
everything it's about the global well
hold on he's smiling with glee here it's
the global medical community in this
regard
you mean like the w-h-o like
just some this isn't some like
pharmaceutical dr fauci push that wasn't
broadly supported by any of the relevant
experts
in the mrna field which is not huge
because it's a very
new development um internationally there
is a demand for these vaccines
oh i wanted to just based on what you
had said i can pull up reuters their
fact check
is that vaccines are not quote cytotoxic
they want to mention that robert malone
uh and they show the the brett weinstein
podcast
they show uh the post the fda was
alerted months ago
that the spike protein and the cover
vaccines are cytotoxic toxic to cells
the fda did nothing
reuters says this is not true now the
issue at hand is
trust like you mentioned you said do you
trust fauci or weinstein
i don't know if there is a fact-based
argument if you have the
the doctors you trust and the doctors
you trust or the organizations you you
trust
it's a it's a clash of who you believe
to be honest none of us have the
credentials
to just come up with these arguments on
their own there will always be bias in
who we choose to believe
however given the plurality of people
seem to support the safety and the
effectiveness of the vaccine and the
fact that it doesn't take a virologist
to notice that
over half a million americans have died
to covet more than the combined death
tolls of every war since world war one
combined
including the second world war in
vietnam those are things that i don't
need to be a virologist to see
can i see can i ask you a question
though pretty bad uh the the
one of the issues that's brought up
frequently especially on twitter is that
many of these covet deaths
are died with covid as it's brought up
where people would say something like uh
it tends to be people who are over 70 or
things like that i'm only bringing that
up not to make the argument but because
you said how would verse know if these
are actually related to vaccines i'd
love to respond to that if i may
absolutely covet rarely like directly
kills you
like age it causes a breakdown in other
vital functions
that then their death can be attributed
to such so for example of the many
things that people die it's not really
coveted it's just that covid blanks
their entire system internally and
eventually something fails something
breaks and they die
um there were people claiming that there
were deaths being spuriously attributed
to covet 19 very early on in this
pandemic
but thankfully we know that's not the
case because if you take a look at the
excess mortality numbers the number of
people who should die every year in the
united states
because there's a very normal pattern
you know normally with this many people
in this country
we see an excess starting when covet
started that
almost perfectly grafts onto the rising
death waves of covet i mean it perfectly
tracks onto that
i just want to say for you charlie i
think you know the issue i i see here is
for me it's i can't trust or distrust i
don't know you know i i think brett
weinstein's a very smart guy and i don't
think he's gonna lie to me and these
doctors are very smart people then i see
the government agencies that
you know i don't always trust the
government becoming honest i'm not a big
fan
but to believe that there's like a
nefarious effort anything like that
ultimately what it comes down to is in
my opinion having a trusted medical
professional that you can consult with
well i totally agree and i think there
could be an argument that if you're over
the age of 70
that this vaccine might be a really good
idea for you
however to mandate it for schools and
for colleges
when these are highly complex medical
decisions that's where i'm going to push
back against it
let me let me let me complex the johnson
johnson vaccine is not an
mrna vaccine though is that that's my
understanding
i i i don't want to speak out of turn i
believe so i would love to be fact
checked on that um i'm not totally sure
at my memory so
i i guess another question i have what
do you think of
alternative type treatments
hydroxychloroquine ivermectin why the
push for mass inoculation
well because well hydroxychloroquine
studies have found it largely
ineffective there was i believe a french
study that stopped when people started
dying of heart failure
i think the only reason the right diet
is in this hills because trump mentioned
it i don't think there'd be a push for
it otherwise
um the vaccines are the effective way of
getting mass populations inoculated and
while it is true that
most of the people who die are ancient
uh the fact remains that people
experience long-term side effects from
getting covet even if they survive
i know people who are in their 30s and
you know me a blistering 27 year old
myself
i'm not especially worried but i've
heard them talk about how much harder it
is for them to climb up flights of
stairs
i know that erectile dysfunction fellas
is one of the listed potential side
effects of getting coveted even young
healthy no
other problems it is true that death is
most
um comorbid with age and pre-existing
conditions but
still and that's not even to speak of
the covet variants i mean right now you
were on what delta
but if it keeps cycling around the world
let it go for another year who knows how
bad this could get
so uh johnson johnson is not an mrna
vaccine
so there's an alternative to mrna if
you're concerned about it
there was some guidance with the nerve
disease with that sorry to interrupt i
i do think we kind of overlooked
something really interesting is that uh
when did we mandate
vaccinations in public schools uh well i
know the supreme court case concerning
this was in 1904
yeah so i would know it would have to
have been earlier than that i know that
washington even had his troops
vaccinated though
for smallpox smallpox was it yeah um
which is pretty crazy
inoculated not back yeah you're right
right i don't know what they did hit
people with a rock and then like it was
like
like a needle i think it was and they
would like they would like prick you
with a needle that had like a weakened
sample and they would have had to forge
that needle like with a blacksmith isn't
that crazy to think about like
washington's true like
they still they i i know like someone
pouring it and then like you know
today it's just a machine that makes it
it's just wild to think about well so
man uh i i think the real issue
for the most part is just mandatory well
i i just also have another question
do you think that there might be any bad
motives behind these four companies
astrazeneca moderna
pfizer and johnson and johnson
considering they are big pharma
and they pursue profits which generally
as a libertarian socialist you're
skeptical of
do you think maybe they might have
nefarious motives oh their intentions
are reprehensible they have for many
years made money off the backs of
american deaths the opioid crisis
is almost entirely attributable to them
and the sackler yeah
i mean no moral love for these companies
if this could be and by the way the mrna
process was developed through public
funding it was you know an
effort invested in by the collective
good something i'm generally supportive
of when it comes to these companies
themselves and when i say you know go
get your pfizer vaccine whatever
please do not mistake this or anything
else that i say for an endorsement of
the practices of these companies
it is only through cruel twist of fate
and the economic system we live in
that they are the ones put in a position
to handle this
but it was the workers of those
companies not the ceos who did the work
i'm just i'm just curious does that ever
make you stop
short and say huh maybe they're trying
to massively inoculate us
on a vaccine that might not be as
effective to try to pursue profit not
well-being does that ever
like enter into your consideration
it's a consideration you should take
about anything produced by any company
that's run for profit which is
everything you know uh basically every
need in american society
need is tempered by the knowledge that
there are people out there who are paid
very large salaries to sell it to you
this is the case for everything we do
everything we eat every time you
run down main street or in my case i
guess um uh uh
you know the boulevards in los angeles
um you're seeing the protracted efforts
of a billion dollar industry to make
sure you want things they're selling
could that be the case for covid
undeniably there was a profit incentive
involved
oh my goodness i'm sorry and there was
probably a protected effort on the part
of these companies to make sure they
were the first and they probably took
every dirty advantage
but with the data available i have to
still and much as i would say hey i
would prefer
eating mcdonald's food to starvation i
have to say this is probably still
something we should be doing do you want
to do i don't want to stay we've it's
been 20 minutes no for sure do you want
to make a final maybe you would starve
and say i actually think this has been
really
constructive and not like that you know
inflammatory
i think that deep down you have this
kind of
you know urge that i'm already there
where maybe they want this thing to go
on for another decade to go make another
hundred billion dollars and maybe
the cheap drug of hydroxychloroquine or
ivormectin might work better than they
might think
i don't have that urge sir other studies
would disagree with you earlier we could
change the topic i just yeah
i just think it's so i'll that was okay
that was a healthy discourse can i meet
in the middle on that one on that very
last one
i do not trust the pharmaceutical
industries though the available evidence
does seem to point to the effectiveness
of the vaccines i say this
uh nationalize the pharma industry
seriously it could be used for the
collective good
and i would unironically actually trust
it more in the hands of our ineffective
bloated government than i would uh the
sociopaths who run it currently
so i'll i'll wrap this up by saying um
always talk to your doctor that this is
one of the biggest things like youtube
is very strict on this especially but i
genuinely think this is the right answer
if you're watching this don't assume
anyone here is right or wrong
i mean there's i'm sure there are people
who think charlie's made a bunch of good
points and you have ultimately it's down
between you and your doctor
and i uh and i'll stress you know uh for
whatever your opinion charlie i
understand
hydroxychloroquine and ivormectin
haven't been approved by the fda
and so that's just another option just
asking questions whether it works or not
so that's why i think it's really
important because i think there there
are
i got to be honest in regards to
ivermectin people have been eating horse
paste
that they sell i looked up what the fda
says about it they say do not do this
and they actually give a very good
reason they say although people are
claiming
that you know if an animal can take it
someone else can that's not true there
are some things that dogs can't have
that humans can
so please talk to your doctor and i i
definitely hope
we can continue having questions debates
about this stuff because
this that that was vastly important i'm
really glad you guys were able to
kind of i hadn't even heard of the horse
pace thing yes ivermectin is technically
a drug for horses it's off label use
oh yeah it's a dewormer and so you can
go to like tractor supply and they have
them they have a sign that says like do
not eat this
and please any drug for horses will burn
a human out from the inside those things
are yeah
you're bending or they're they're titans
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you